these two men
andrew carnegie and john d rockefeller
lied cheated killed people destroyed
communities all in pursuit of economic
power they were known as the robber
barons of capitalism and they hated that
so they said about changing their image
they wanted people to forget about all
the terrible things they did so carnegie
built public libraries rockefeller set
up foundations they found a way to con
the establishment into moving on
that's what we're seeing today with
these two
bush and biden want you to forget about
what they did they're desperate for
praise and pats on the back from the
establishment but unlike the original
robber barons who at least did some good
with their deflection tactics from bush
and biden it is entirely negative in the
past few days they have cynically come
together to attack a common enemy
republicans
disgracefully george w bush used the
anniversary of 911 to imply that
republicans the people who put him in
the oval office are like the 911
terrorists and no he didn't just mean
those who committed crimes bush knew
perfectly well how his remarks would be
amplified he intended to smear the
republican base
what a sick cynical transparently
self-interested ploy to ingratiate
himself with the media and the political
establishment does bush really think
it's going to make americans forget what
he did
instead it's done the exact opposite it
prompts us to remember that george w
bush let osama bin laden slip through
his fingers in december 2001 because
bush was too busy dialing up plans for
the invasion of iraq we remember that
bush took us to war in iraq on a lie and
according to those around him at the
time he did it just to look tougher than
his father an actual war hero
we remember that bush's war of vanity
squandered the sympathy and unity of the
civilized world after 9 11 we remember
we will never forget however many
portraits he paints or speeches he makes
sucking up to the establishment and its
elitist group thing we will never forget
that george w bush caused the death of
millions needlessly that he destabilized
the middle east pointlessly that he took
trillions of dollars of your money
corruptly and put it in the pockets of
his cronies led of course by the chinese
whose family business is war
fought by other people and their
children
biden said he wanted to end a war not
just overseas but here at home
we must end this uncivil war
that pits red against blue
rural versus ireland or rural versus
urban
conservative versus liberal
well
just as his abject surrender to the
taliban has not stopped but restarted
the endless war as afghanistan once
again becomes a safe haven for
terrorists biden is not ending our
uncivil war but reviving it he picks a
fight over the pandemic hoping we'll
forget about the chaos he created at the
southern border the humanitarian crisis
the security crisis the immigration
crisis he thinks we'll forget about his
crime crisis his inflation crisis he
thinks we'll forget that he was elected
on a pledge to bring the country
together and yet every single thing he
says or does is designed to drive us
further apart he thinks we'll forget
that he was elected as a moderate a
centrist and yet he's now the front man
for the most extreme far-left
centralizing federal government
expansion in american history
biden thinks we'll forget that he can
barely string two sentences together
when he can they make no sense
even in the moment that he's trying to
distract us from his lies and failures
the bottom line
we're going to protect vaccinated
workers from unvaccinated co-workers
what
protect the vaccinated from the
unvaccinated yeah it's called a vaccine
can we just stop for a second
and describe accurately what we saw
there on thursday
either we saw a president who went off
script and made something up that
directly contradicts science and the
stated aims of his administration
or it was in the script and he
successfully read it out
in which case we have an entire white
house operation that has the president
of the united states saying things that
contradict science and the stated aims
of the administration this is not a joke
folks
this is a crisis of
governance in the very act of trying to
get us to move on biden reminds us why
we must not
and of course more than anything that
applies to his greatest catastrophe his
cruel narcissistic bid to be the guy who
stopped the endless war at any cost
whether that's dead marines in
afghanistan or another 911 plotted there
or americans and our allies stranded
behind enemy lines desperate fearing for
their lives in the hands of those who
attacked us 20 years ago what a
grotesque way to commemorate the bravery
the heroism the sacrifice of so many
americans not just on that day
but in the two decades since
biden
surrendering to the taliban leaving our
people behind leaving our military
equipment behind yeah leaving our
morality behind
this appalling biden regime cruel weak
incompetent still can't seem to
comprehend the gravity of what they've
done listen to this
from the state department when
challenged about why they're not letting
planes take off and getting americans
out this is an actual official statement
released last sunday quote we understand
the concern that many people are feeling
as they try to facilitate further
charter and other passage out of
afghanistan however we do not have
personnel on the ground we do not have
air assets in the country we do not
control the airspace whether over
afghanistan or elsewhere in the region
yeah exactly that's the whole point you
ran away and now you can't help
americans and you're talking about it as
if it's just some kind of immutable fact
of life no you took the personnel off
the ground you took the air assets out
of the country you're the ones who did
this and now you turn around and ring
your hands about it you really are the
lowest of the low
actually no there was a lower point
what was the word the white house used
to describe the murderous torturing
terrorists they handed americans over to
professional
professional
here's a word for that
despicable
just like their drone strike a shameless
political move straight out of that
movie wag the dog we're now learning
the biden regime mistook
water canisters for bombs and killed an
aid worker and nine other civilians
and this is their great over-the-horizon
anti-terror strategy it's not so much
over the horizon as somewhere over the
rainbow god help us next time if they're
looking at bombs and think they're water
canisters
and then they have the nerve to suggest
that all this strengthens america
because it frees us up to concentrate on
the real threat from china
they're right about the threat but the
idea that this weak feckless biden
regime will ever stand up to china well
all you need to know about that is the
readout from biden's phone call with xi
jinping this week this is an actual
quote from a white house official biden
sought to explain u.s actions towards
china quote
in a way that is not misinterpreted as
somehow trying to sort of undermine
beijing in particular ways
so that's biden's strategy on the threat
that his whole afghan disaster was
supposed to enable him to protect us
from
not somehow sort of undermining beijing
no wonder there are reports that china
is taking over bagram the strategic
asset that biden just gave up overnight
biden is totally out of his depth
he is nothing but a corrupt machine
politician with no principles no
integrity no decency his entire
presidency is a fraud he said he'd bring
compassion but instead gave us cruelty
he promised competence but delivered
chaos he was elected as a moderate
centrist but the minute he's sworn in
it's a far-left socialist takeover he
was running around yesterday complaining
about the f biden signs he saw from his
convoy
honestly
considering the damage he's done to this
country that is a mild rebuke
as we said last week if he won't resign
he must be impeached